[Musica]
buonasera a tutti e tutti se la paura il
buio la conoscenza e la luce la
meraviglia cos'è la meraviglia e un
momento è un tempo e quell'istante
preciso in cui accendendosi la luce noi
ci meravigliamo ossia non ci aspettavamo
quello che dovevamo vedere ci
aspettavamo qualcos'altro
perché in realtà in realtà noi diamo
tante cose per scontate
diamo per scontata tutta la realtà diamo
per scontata
addirittura la stessa oggettività della
realtà in qualche modo siamo convinti
sempre delle nostre ragioni e di avere
ragioni e poi succede che magari qualche
fenomeno qualcosa che capita ci fa
dubitare ci fa dubitare della stessa
oggettività della realtà
e allora ad esempio se noi potessimo
scoperchiare questo teatro e guardassimo
fuori e ci fossero le condizioni giuste
e ci fosse un meraviglioso arcobaleno in
cielo beh ognuno di noi vedrebbe un
arcobaleno differente non sarebbe una
realtà oggettiva per ognuno di noi
sarebbe una realtà soggettiva
voi sapete che l'arcobaleno e la
rifrazione della luce su milioni di
particelle e quindi probabilmente voi
vedreste tutti quanti siete un
arcobaleno diverso da un punto di vista
diverso più colorato meno più spostato
magari io non vedere neanche ognuno di
noi vede le cose con occhi diversi le
vede le vede per quello che è perché una
donna perché un uomo perché più giovane
perché meno giovane perché
perché ha un orientamento sessuale
affettivo perché ha un orientamento
politico perché ha un orientamento di
qualunque tipo
in realtà ogni volta che vediamo la
realtà la vediamo in una maniera molto
diversa
e qual è il problema però di questo
perché non dovrebbe essere un problema
questo avrebbe una cosa bella
potrebbe essere un modo di vedere il
mondo no il problema è che noi vogliamo
avere ragione che la nostra realtà e la
realtà oggettiva per noi non ci credete
ci accaniamo è adesso voglio fare voglio
fargli una prova gli mandi la slide e
per fare l'ho fatto apposta
sognavo di fare questo da quando l'ho
vista la prima volta allora mi puoi
accendere un secondo la platea che
voglio partecipare rendere tutti
partecipi di questa cosa
adesso che siamo qua così tanti e tante
facciamo una prova ma adesso io voglio
fermi a dovete solo fare un alzata di
mano non vi chiedo niente quindi fate la
voglio che alzino la mano solo e dico
solo le persone che vedono queste scarpe
rosa e bianche alla faccia passa mi
sento diversa davvero io ok giù le mani
adesso se non riesce faccio una
figuraccia alzano la mano le persone che
vedono queste scarpe grigie e verde
acqua azzurro beh grazie
scusate siamo alla minoranza volevo
dirvelo ma per ora siamo sempre meglio
come al solito allora volevo dire questo
c'è qualcuno che vede le scarpe
sforzandosi facendo un gioco mentale le
vede in entrambi i modi riesce a
sbucciare una due tre quattro venti reti
che ancora ancora peggio siete a quello
di una violenza
allora io non so qualcuno di voi lo
conoscete sicuramente lo conoscete già
la conoscete già questa immagine la cosa
importante fermi silenzio la cosa
importante non è tanto lo so che tutti
vi state chiedendo ma di che colore sono
le scarpe
stiamo facendo un discorso stiamo
cercando di capire cosa sentiamo noi
cosa intendo ok no cioè possiamo anche
io mi posso anche vedere tutti che mi
piace però se vuoi puoi anche rispetto
che magari mi vedete meglio ok allora
stiamo cercando di capire un'altra cosa
cioè di capire che cosa succede in noi
quando ci rendiamo conto che la realtà
che vede qualcun altro è molto diversa
da quello che vediamo noi cosa succede
allora nell'ordine io per esempio
personalmente ho provato prima mi sono
accanita gli ho detto ma cosa stai
dicendo
il problema è che mi sono accanita e
fortemente e discutevo con due bambine
di 7 anni cioè le mie figlie che
logicamente ma scusa sono bianche rosa
ecco l'unica cosa che devo dire che loro
due non si sono minimamente
scandalizzate quando gliel'ho detto
credevo un'altra cosa
questa è una differenza che tornerà
anche dopo ci fa capire molto no dei
bambini e delle bambine
noi invece no è no io prima ero lì
dietro
e qualcuno mi fa è comunque queste
scarpe sono rose bianche ho capito ma
non è che sì perché non esistono in
commercio quelle grigie i verdi ok
allora facciamo un passo indietro
non è un problema che sia oggettiva
un'oggettiva la realtà perché questo è
un mega problema mio problema che la
filosofia tratta da mille anni non so da
tanto comunque lo tratta veramente da
tanto e la questione è capire noi come
percepiamo la questione come la
percepiamo nel senso come ci risulta che
qualcun altro abbia un'idea
completamente diversa dalla nostra
in questo caso addirittura in una
percezione c'è una convinzione tale che
ha a che fare con la realtà
e perché noi non riusciamo con l'altra
persona a creare quel dialogo che superi
le posizioni che si renda conto che se
ognuno nel punto di vista diverso anche
molto
caspita ma questo vuol dire arricchire
tantissimo il nostro modo di vedere la
realtà perché vediamo la realtà anche in
altri modi
è una specie di super potere
invece no invece il mondo odierno ci
porta a polarizzare tutto ci porta a
vedere e dire ho ragione io hai ragione
tu io sto da questa parte tu stai
dall'altro perché succede questo
facciamo un passo indietro e cerchiamo
di capire come funziona il nostro
sistema cognitivo come conosciamo la
realtà la cercherò di farla molto bene
però in realtà noi facciamo una serie di
cose che fanno tutti abbiamo le stesse
dinamiche cognitive agli stessi
automatismi scorciatoie assumiamo delle
credenze delle convinzioni soprattutto
facciamo proprio delle attività mentali
dei percorsi che ripetiamo che tra
l'altro il mondo dell'economia conosce
bene visto che ci vendono la qualunque e
soprattutto sul digitale e incorriamo
nelle stesse negli stessi processi ad
esempio la nostra mente deve risolvere
alcuni problemi enormi
il primo problema ci sono troppe
informazioni troppe informazioni da
gestire
fate conto che sono stati stimati circa
11 milioni di bit all'istante di cui noi
riusciamo a elaborare una quantità
razionale in 40 bit cioè noi lavoriamo
40 bit su 11 milioni e per farlo
un grande premio nobel daniel kahneman e
ci ha raccontato e poi molti altri ce
l'hanno spiegato facciamo una cosa
semplicissima utilizziamo e la nostra il
nostro pensiero veloce io ve la faccio
più semplice utilizziamo un pensiero
così veloce perché altrimenti
praticamente insieme estinti con tutto
quello che dobbiamo decidere pensare
nelle
con temperamento e un istante ed è una
specie di una sorta di nostro doppio
diciamo che la nostra parte pensante
veloci assomiglia un po a homer simpson
corsia è un pensiero sociale in qualche
modo il pensiero di qualcun altro non è
solo il nostro e quello che usiamo anche
per capire per rendere più probabile
possibile la scelta che farò cioè
renderla diciamo ottenere il massimo
delle probabilità dalla scelta che sto
facendo e scarta sempre qualcosa perché
quella scelta potrebbe non essere
corretta vi faccio degli esempi pratici
noi generalizziamo pensiamo non so che
tutte le persone anziane siano l'ente o
magari non digitali che le persone
giovani magari siano più entusiaste che
tutte le donne abbiano voglia di essere
madri oppure che il papa non siano i
maschi non siano capaci come genitori
perché maschi beh noi generalizziamo
tutto e poi ci scordiamo invece di
guardare cosa succede nella realtà io
sono una madre che naturalmente più
grande di me
eppure è decisamente più digitale di me
ea volte anche più entusiasti e facciamo
tante cose che hanno a che fare con le
razioni le relazioni con gli altri per
esempio scegliamo le persone simili a
noi perché è più comodo perché è più
facile perché le persone simili a noi ci
fanno faticare meno
e allora se provate a immaginare a
pensare alle cinque persone di cui vi
fidate di più la fiducia pensiamo sia un
meccanismo razionale della nostra mente
invece pensate alle 100 liete i
familiari per favore perché non valgono
le cinque persone 123 insomma le persone
di cui vi fidate di più e provate a
immaginare per esempio a pensare dal
punto di vista del genere del sesso se
hanno il vostro stesso sesso oppure no
l'orientamento sessuale affettivo sono
etero gay lesbiche o bisessuali siano
stesso accento se non sono se sono della
stessa generazione
beh o della stessa religione lo stesso
credo
se fate la somma vedete che quelle hicks
aumentano noi scegliamo persone simili a
noi
ebbene come si fa invece a comprendere
il valore di arrivare a qualcosa di più
distante la nostra mente è come una
specie di voglio fare un esempio io una
nonna che faceva la sarta e la sua
miglior amica era una signora che una
merceria erano merceria stupenda in
realtà sembrava un po sapete come il
film matrix quando lui a un certo punto
fa armi e vengono fuori chilometri di
scaffali di armi ecco era la merceria
dell'amica di mia nonna però c'erano
chilometri di scaffali di bottoni e la
nostra mente è questo noi apriamo un
cassetto abbiamo centinaia di bottoni a
rossi a tre buchi però non possiamo
usare ogni volta prima tutti i cassetti
della mente ogni ragionamento veloce che
dobbiamo fare quindi cosa facciamo
in realtà puntiamo come faceva l'app
l'amica di mia nonna
puntiamo e come credo che si faccia in
tutte le mercerie onestamente un bottone
simbolico di quello che c'è dentro con
l'asca di tutti tutto quello che c'è in
quel cassetto è quello è il nostro
modello è il nostro modello è lo
stereotipo lo sterotipo non è per forza
negativo è il modello con cui ragioniamo
così non possiamo tenere tutti i
cassetti chiusi dare un occhio
velocemente fare il nostro ragionamento
usando quei concetti quelli sono
concetti che non non sono i nostri
concetti preferiti i nostri propri
concetti quelli sono i concetti che ci
servono comunicare con noi con gli altri
e quindi la mia idea di macchina avrà
una macchinina puntata sopra sul mio
cassettino però se io parlo con voi
probabilmente usiamo quella stessa idea
di macchina ma se io inizio a parlare
con qualcuno che vive negli stati uniti
o in india o in cina non è detto che io
riesca a capirmi su tutti i concetti e
faccio più fatica perché devo iniziare
aprire i cassetti
se vogliono realmente capirmi
io voglio che ci capiamo no e allora
cosa succede succede che questo riguarda
tutti riguarda il concetto di famiglia
il concetto di sesso riguarda tutti
riguarda qualcosa che ha a che fare con
qualcuno vicino a noi potremmo avere un
concetto diverso qui rispetto a quello
che viene detto a milano ho fatto a
milano
oppure che è distante per età o per
genere
vi siete mai chiesti come magari può
essere difficile appunto parlare di
sesso con qualcuno che ha un'età molto
diversa dalla nostra
oppure parlare di sesso con qualcuno che
ha un'età uguale alla nostra ma magari
una qualche disabilità
noi non abbiamo i codici ci imbarazzano
non sappiamo iniziamo aprire piuttosto
non ne parliamo
ecco il valore di riuscire a dialogare
non a litigare con qualcuno che è molto
distante e difficile è difficile e anche
parlare di di politica con qualcuno che
è distante da noi anzi forse ancora di
più
eppure la verità è che è solo da ciò che
è molto diverso che in realtà si può
ottenere qualcosa di innovativo
sono idee diverse che ti fanno crescere
io la chiamo diciamo una strana legge
della matematica delle idee
se due persone sono davvero diverse
il loro prodotto c'è la loro unione
elimina della loro idea è una
moltiplicazione cioè un prodotto se
arriva molto più avanti tutta
l'evoluzione l'evoluzione umana la
produzione e la biologia ci insegna che
la diversità fa evolvere
se due persone sono molto simili se io e
te abbiamo in fondo le stesse idee ma
che poi è quello che siamo nelle nostre
bolle internet le nostre bolle dei
social network eccetera se abbiamo le
stesse idee
cosa facciamo le condividiamo al massimo
costruiamo qualcosa di molto simile
oppure potremmo somari c ecco due
persone simili si sommano al massimo
è un valore immenso riuscire a capire
che c'è bisogno del dialogo che non c'è
bisogno della della polarizzazione e
questa cosa è una nostra responsabilità
di tutti è una responsabilità nel
momento in cui scriviamo parliamo
ma nel momento in cui non solo lo
diciamo ai nostri figli oi figli e le
figlie degli altri perché siamo
insegnanti perché siamo medici
professionisti eccetera eccetera ma una
responsabilità su di noi perché siamo un
esempio perché siamo dei modelli anche
noi perché perché il mondo migliora così
e allora l'invito
l'invito che faccio in realtà a tutti è
di non avere paura di accendere quella
luce solo perché non si sa quello che si
potrà trovare in quella stanza perché
usiamo quello stupore rendiamo quella
paura meraviglia perché solo
meravigliandoci che riusciamo a cambiare
il mondo e un pochino facendo quello che
facevamo da piccoli perché in fondo da
piccoli le cose si conoscono sempre per
la prima volta e adesso che ne
riconosciamo
[Applauso]